Wow you've just come out of Avengers
infinity war you've cheered it all the
fights laughter all the jokes you've
been shaken speechless and sobbing
you've made an appointment for therapy
for tomorrow don't worry we're all right
there with you it's only one cure for
the post infinity war blues and that's
diving straight into the ending and
trying to figure out what the hell just
happened and what the hell is gonna
happen next
strap in put your helmet on and prepare
your haunches people here's the ending
of Avengers infinity war explained and
of course gigantic earth-shattering
spoilers ahead last chance to turn back
so what just happened Thanos won can you
believe it the bad guy beat the good
guys in his totally mind-blowing because
that kind that never happens but it did
this time and it was just about perfect
Thanos managed to assemble all six of
the Infinity stones sacrificing his own
adopted daughter in the process snapped
his fingers and poof and game over man
of course fans of the comics an MCU
followers probably knew going into the
movie but there was a good chance an O
to be victorious before the final
credits roll longtime comic book readers
have the image of Sano slapping his
fingers with a fully powered Infinity
Gauntlet on his hand burned into their
brains so it only makes sense that one
of the most iconic moments in all of
Marvel Comics history would show up in
this film on top of that we all knew
that Marvel will be splitting the story
into two movies even if they later
publicly reversed course on that
particular point in the end if you
didn't know that photos might pull out
the W by the end of this movie you
haven't been paying close attention body
counts when it comes to writing about
comic book movies it's pretty fun to try
and predictable live and who will die
when the next big flake hits the
theaters in fact making these kinds of
predictions is basically how some
YouTube channels go about building their
whole business
wink wink but even still no one could
have predicted just how many hugely
important super heroic characters would
go off to that big comic book store in
the sky by the end of infinity war for
those keeping score at home
we lost Bucky Black Panther Scarlet
Witch Falcon tracks Doctor Strange
spider-man star-lord mantis brute Nick
Fury and Maria hill and those are just
the characters we saw dissolve after
Thanos poured his big Trek it was a lot
and that's not even a complete list of
all the dead people right off the bat
Heimdall and Loki died at Thanos his
hands vulgar more and
went down for the counts as well after
10 years and 18 movies the Marvel
Cinematic Universe built up a huge
roster of memorable and important
characters while it goes without saying
that the vast majority of these dead
people were not stayed dead by the time
the fourth Avengers movie debuts it's
hard not to feel the loss of so many
characters we've gotten to know over the
years where did fan who's talked to
Gamora towards the end of the film
fallows appeared at an orange e radish
place and began talking with a version
of Gamora who looked like a child we've
never seen that place before in the film
so where was a there's a more than
decent chance that he was inside the
orange soulstone itself
Thanos sacrificed Gamora to obtain the
soul stone and so it makes sense as she
and the stone would be connected somehow
after her death and then the various
comics concerning Thanos and his quest
for the Infinity stones the soul gem
wound up playing host to a few
characters who died fighting Pharaohs
including Gamora and with that in mind
it's entirely possible that all our dead
heroes may have had their souls
transported to the soul stone as well
dr. Strange's prescription for victory
early on at Doctor Strange told Iron Man
that if it came down to possibly saving
him or protecting the time stone he'd
choose a stone then around the midpoint
of the film Doctor Strange used the eye
of agamotto to explore over 14 million
possible battles against Thanos looking
for the path to victory in all of those
possible futures he only saw one where
the good guys came out on top it sure
sounded dire but when Thanos threatened
to kill Iron Man on Titan Doctor Strange
offered the time stone to save Tony
Stark's life when I a man called him out
on it later he said it was the only way
Sehwa well it all makes sense if you
think about it
Doctor Strange has some experience using
his time powers to cheat his way out of
some bad situations
[Music]
this time around he took a peek at the
script for the next Avengers movie and
realized that it was important the Iron
Man lived to the end important enough
that he gave up the time stone to make
sure it happens and considering the Iron
Man is the one who kicked off this whole
crazy Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
first place it only makes sense that it
be pretty necessary to finishing things
off over a decade later nebulas revenge
among the movies survivors with Santos's
Lee's favorite daughter
nebula she managed to make it to the end
of the movie despite being literally
dissected earlier in the film so why
would a scrub like nebula be alive for
so many fan favorite characters got
turned to dust as with so many things
the answer lies in the comics in the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book storyline
nebula spent a lot of time shambling
around as a creepy zombie lady a victim
of Thanos his power but at one point in
the story Thanos was distracted by an
encounter with eternity a cosmic being
that represented the universe itself
that's when nebula grabbed his fancy
glove for herself and contributed to his
eventual undoing don't be surprised that
the MCU version of nebula winds up
fulfilling a similar role in the next
Avengers movie to paging Captain Marvel
in the movies one post-credit scene we
saw the long-awaited return of Nick Fury
Maria Hill trying to get in touch with
somebody given that would spent a full
movie not seeing Hawkeye shooting arrows
at anybody it seemed like a foregone
conclusion that he was the guy fury was
trying to reach but as it turned out he
was actually trying to get in touch with
Captain Marvel fans of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe know that brie Larson
is all set to debut as the MC use first
female fronted superhero movie in March
2019 a couple months before the release
of the next Avengers movie interestingly
Captain Marvel is supposedly going to
take place in the 1990s meaning that a
superhero who shows up to save the day
in the fourth Avengers will have already
been established in some capacity for
years so where she'd been for all the
other super shenanigans over the last
bunch of movies about Hawkeye we never
did get a glimpse of Hawkeye after all
meaning everyone's favorite Archer is
surely going to show up in the next
Avengers movie right he's a necessary
part of the team she
flying we're fighting an army of robots
and I have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense
ok maybe is not that necessary but still
every hero helps right it's his family
ok in the aftermath of Thanos his dirty
deeds that he possibly be looking to
avenge them and everyone else on earth
perhaps if we can't protect the Earth
you can be damn well sure we'll avenge
it thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]